- [Narrator] An economic crisis is looming
and experts are sounding
the alarm, afraid of-
- Self-imposed calamity.
- [Narrator] Treasury
Secretary Janet Yellen
is talking about the dispute
over raising the debt ceiling,
which hasn't happened yet.
- Can't be negotiated over whether or not
we're going to pay our bills.
- [Narrator] But as the
countdown to potential calamity
ticks closer to zero,
the US Treasury is
buying America more time
by taking so-called extraordinary measures
because if the government
hits its borrowing limit-
- You have a real mess on your hands.
- [Narrator] So what are
these extraordinary measures?
How do they help avoid a crisis?
And what happens when they've run out?
First, it's important to understand
what makes them extraordinary.
The Treasury pays the country's bills
by using revenue from taxes,
because it spends more than it taxes,
it makes up the difference by issuing debt
in the form of government securities.
But there is a self-imposed
congressional limit
to how much of this debt
the department can issue.
That's the ceiling.
- The only way to fund a
deficit is to borrow more money
and until it gets rid of the deficit
that debt is going to keep rising.
- [Narrator] It's on Congress
to raise that ceiling
to allow the Treasury to issue more debt,
and cover spending that
lawmakers already approved,
but there's a cap on how much
debt the department can issue,
that limit-
- The debt ceiling.
- If all this sudden
overnight you can't borrow
any more money,
well, then you start missing
payments that you've promised.
- [Narrator] This is where
the Treasury comes in
with its extraordinary measures
to prevent the country from
reaching the debt ceiling.
- The Treasury uses these
extraordinary measures
because it's got no alternative.
If it can't borrow more money,
it's gotta find the money somewhere.
- [Narrator] So the Treasury
accesses other funds
it has tucked away,
pulling money from one area
to use for more pressing
spending needs in another.
- Imagine that you have an
envelope hidden away in a drawer
with a bunch of cash in
it to deal with a crisis,
this is the envelope.
- [Narrator] But how does
the Treasury get that cash?
One way is by using
money it has stowed away
for its own retirees.
On January 19th, Yellen
announced the Treasury
would be redeeming investments
from the Civil Service
Retirement and Disability Fund
and the Postal Service
Retiree Health Benefits Fund.
They're one of the tools in the envelope.
Pulling investments doesn't
shut down these funds
or mean that retirees
won't get their payments.
It does mean that these
funds will be tapped now
while extraordinary measures continue.
Another way is by pausing investments.
On January 23rd, Yellen paused investments
in the Government
Securities Investment Fund,
which is invested in short
term US Treasury securities.
In addition, the Treasury
can pause payments
to government funds
that don't have to
immediately pay beneficiaries.
But the Treasury doesn't
just take and pause
without refilling the envelope.
- Typically, after the
debt ceiling is increased,
they'll borrow money from the the public,
from bond investors,
and then replenish those pension accounts
that it's taken from.
- [Narrator] However, the
Treasury's extraordinary measures
are temporary meant only
to tie the government over
until the debt ceiling is raised.
- The end of the day,
Congress simply has to act
to raise the debt ceiling.
- House Republicans on the other hand
want to use the debt ceiling
as leverage to force a debate
with Democrats about cutting
spending to curb future debt.
- It doesn't matter if you sit
before a four star general,
they'll tell you the debt
is the greatest threat
to this nation.
- [Narrator] This has become
something of a recurring political fight.
- Let's pay our bills,
not torch our economy.
- In the past, they've always
raised the debt ceiling
and tried to get back to
some state of normalcy.
If they run out of funds
in using these extraordinary measures,
and they haven't run the debt ceiling,
then they don't pay their bills.
- [Narrator] Yellen said
that she expected them
to keep the government from
hitting the debt ceiling
until early June.
If the ceiling isn't
raised and the Treasury
can't meet all of its
obligations, the US defaults.
It's called the X-date,
and it's never happened
in American history.
So what would happen?
- Bond holders don't get paid interest,
retirees don't get paid
social security funds,
contractors don't get paid
for military spending,
and then you've got a
real mess on your hands.
- [Narrator] That mess
could cause a disaster
in financial markets.
- It is possible for markets
to become quite concerned
about whether or not the
US will pay its bills
before the day of reckoning comes.
- [Narrator] That could even mean
a possible credit downgrade.
- One of the last times
we had a moment like this
was Standard & Poor's
downgraded the AAA credit rating
on US Treasury securities.
- After witnessing a month of wrangling
over raising the debt ceiling,
they doubted our political
systems' ability to act.
- There are real consequences
if we get to a moment
where extraordinary measures are exhausted
and the US has no way
to continue to fund its budget deficits.
- [Narrator] The Treasury says
the US won't reach the X-date
until this summer.
In the meantime, the
Treasury will continue
implementing extraordinary measures
until the debt ceiling is raised
or that emergency envelope is empty.
(upbeat music)